i'm in boston i flew here yesterday on
my first flight
since that hero judge struck down the
cdc's mask mandate
and 99
of the people in the airport
loved it we were happy as a clan i would
say i'm just i'm just estimating here 99
of the people in the airport were not
wearing masks on my flight even a flight
to a liberal city i would say 95
of the people were not wearing masks
they were so so happy
and the lifting of the mask mandate the
fact that it's now
voluntary allows you to tell with 100
certainty exactly who the libs are on
your flight and there actually are not a
whole lot of them everyone was very very
happy
except for
dr fauci i was both surprised and
disappointed because those types of
things really are the purview of the cdc
this is a public health issue
and for a court to come in and if you
look at the rationale for that it really
is not particularly firm
and we are concerned about that about
courts getting involved in things that
are unequivocally public health
decisions i mean this is a cdc issue it
should not have been a court issue so
we're hoping
that the inevitable increase in cases
which we're seeing are not going to be
associated with an increase in
hospitalizations
so all of these dynamic things going on
at the same time it was perfectly
logical
for the cdc to say wait a minute
we were planning on ending this mandate
on a certain date let's wait a period of
time until may 3rd
which was a very sound public health
decision
i hope you've gotten this by now but if
you haven't
this isn't about the masks
this isn't about whether or not you
should wear the stupid masks dr fauci
himself has been the most pro-mask and
anti-mask politician in the country it's
not about the masks this is about
who governs us
dr fauci believes that we should be
governed by the whims and caprices of
totally unaccountable bureaucrats at the
cdc
normal people believe that we should
have some say in our government if we're
not going to be ruled by the legislature
at the very least we could be ruled by
the courts where there's some sort of
kind of almost accountability dr fauci
is furious not because people are not
muzzling themselves anymore but because
for now at least he's no longer running
the country i'm michael knowles is the
michael known show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from astora noble
who says chris said that democrat
positions become far more popular when
they lie about what their position
actually is that's true actually it's
very nice of chris hahn to come on the
show yesterday he is a democrat i wanted
to hear out his side for the
educational in florida and also the
disney retaliation against the education
law and then the florida republican
retaliation against the
disney retaliation against the education
law and what chris said was he really
loves the way democrats have spun this
thing because while don't say gay is not
an accurate representation of the law
politically it can be useful so he's
admitting this is cynical and it's not
really
honest it's not representing what the
law does but it's politically useful and
my only argument there is
i don't think it is all that politically
useful i think the majority of americans
majority of floridians the majority of
democrats even
support the florida education law so i
just don't think it worked i think the
credibility of the left whether we're
talking about the cdc whether we're
talking about fouchy whether we're
talking about the weird groomers at
disney and elsewhere
i just don't think it's there i think
it's beginning to crack
now when you want to make sure that your
home security is very solid i would
strongly recommend you check out ring
right now go to ring.com
knowles it will be one small gadget for
your home but one giant leap for home
security one giant leaper home security
that is what cnet says about ring alarm
pro which is a phenomenal product you
know ring has the video doorbell i've
been telling you about it for years and
then ring has an award-winning alarm
well that's great that way you can
protect your whole home terrific well
now you got to go pro
because you don't just live your life in
the physical world you don't just live
your life in the physical home you spend
a lot of your life in the digital world
in your digital home and you got to
protect that too ring alarm pro does
both it's a combined home security
system and
wi-fi router so that you will feel
secure whether you're in the home
whether you're down the street whether
you're at the office maybe you guys are
on the other side of the world with a
ring protect pro subscription which is
an amazing deal by the way you can get
professional monitoring for the ultimate
peace of mind if anything happens the
professional monitoring will call and
can request emergency services go to
ring.com knowles right now and go pro
with the ring alarm pro that is ring.com
knowles ring.com
knowles the credibility the authority of
the ruling class is cracking
that's why dr fauci is so upset
he actually had the audacity to say
i only wanted two more weeks that's what
he said because the mask mandate on the
airplanes was supposed to expire on
april 18th and then he said look the cdc
i think very responsibly
said that we just need two more weeks of
them oh two more weeks huh where have i
heard two more weeks before you jerk i
heard two weeks two years ago and then
you never gave up your power so you know
what we're gonna take the power back
from you and if we can't even do it
through the legislature then we'll do it
through the courts and this hero
district judge who struck down the mask
mandate
great that's what we're gonna come on
just two more weeks guys no
people
are not buying it anymore
we're not buying that it's only going to
be two weeks
we're not buying that the masks are
going to save us from armageddon we're
not buying what dr fauci
is selling we're not buying what the
liberal establishment is selling broadly
that's why cnn plus the cnn subscription
service is collapsing it's being shut
down
21 days after it started
21 days that's
less than two scaramucci's a scaramucci
is a discreet measurement of time it's
11 days the length that anthony
scaramucci lasted in the white house
these guys didn't even make it to
scaramucci's warner brothers discovery
is reportedly and according to lots of
reports shutting down the new cnn
subscription service
cnbc reported last week fewer than 10
000 people were using cnn plus on a
daily basis
to put that in perspective that's
gosh what is that something like 1 30th
between 130th and 150th the number of
people who watch and listen to this show
every day
this show is a pretty big show but it's
not even the biggest show out there on
the internet this show is getting
between 30 and 50 times the viewership
that cnn was getting on a daily basis
that is pathetic
that it just
it just didn't work
and so
they set this goal of having two million
subscribers to cnn plus
within the first few
years of the services launch nobody's
watching it it looks like they're going
to cut their losses why i could have
told them that this was going to happen
no one in their bubble could have told
them this was going to happen because
they have relied on brute force to
maintain whatever position they have in
public discourse it for
not just recent years really recent
decades
people don't make the decision actively
i'm going to go subscribe to cnn i don't
even think they make the decision to go
watch cnn i think it's just kind of on i
think people we joke about how the only
time people watch cnn is in the airports
well there's a lot of truth to that joke
and why do people watch cnn on their tvs
on the rare occasions that they do
because it's just on and cnn is bundled
as part of cable packages and you're not
going to go in i don't even subscribe to
cable but people who do subscribe to
cable are going to go they're not going
to go in and say i want every channel
except for cnn they're just going to
take and it'll be on and they'll flick
through the channels and that's that but
with cnn plus
that subscription service requires you
to actively go out put down your credit
card say i want cnn and no one wants cnn
i'm not even just scoring cheap partisan
points no one actively wants it it's
just there as background noise as a
propaganda arm for the ruling class
which
increasingly is losing its credibility
all these guys are losing their
credibility jen saki we played around
the show yesterday spokesman for the
president was crying literally crying on
camera over the prospect of not being
able to trans the kids so gensake
on chris wallace's new
new soon to be old cnn plus program to
discuss this law chris wallace was
basically fair about the law and about
the question of transgendering the kids
and jen saki doubled down on it saying
that five-year-olds and six
six-year-olds are questioning their sex
and ought to be affirmed in their
delusions
i understand that it's it's an
emotionally fraught issue i understand
that some of the supporters of the bill
have used inflammatory language saying
that that opponents of the bill want to
sexualize children or groom children
on the other hand
don't parents have a right to have
concern i mean we're talking
specifically here about teaching about
sex in kindergarten through third grade
i have to say as a parent i would have
problems with that
but the law is not about teaching sex
education it's about teaching about
gender identity and so what what do you
do if a parent or a kid should i say a
kid in one of these elementary schools
says
what about sally sally has two moms or
i'm not sure if i'm a girl or a boy i
mean these are kids who are experiencing
um you know these moments in their lives
i also think that these are not there's
not a big record of there being either
sex education or extensive gender
identity education in these schools and
this is creating a problem or a
political cudgel about an issue that i
don't think exists
jen saki made a really big mistake here
and she did the thing that i keep
pointing out that the libs do except she
actually did it backwards usually what
the libs do is say this issue that's
being addressed by the florida education
bill doesn't exist it's not happening at
all and it's really important that the
issue does exist
and she just did it backwards here she
said it's so this is so awful this
florida education bill this is going to
really hurt kids you know
sally with two mommies and you know the
five-year-old who thinks that he's
actually a girl this is really going to
hurt these kids it's going to hurt them
so bad that i'm going to cry on camera
i'm gonna literally cry tears on camera
but it's not happening it doesn't matter
it's not doing anything it's addressing
a problem that doesn't exist well if the
problem doesn't exist why are you crying
jen
if the problem doesn't exist why are you
trying to tug on my heart strings about
sally who doesn't have two mommies sally
has a mommy and a daddy somewhere i
don't know where the mommy and the daddy
are and i don't know what weird social
experiment is messing with sally's head
but whatever sally has she doesn't have
two mommies because that's not how
biology works that's not how babies are
made
that's not even a discussion the
kindergartner should be having in the
classroom how babies are made but
i guess the teacher should know the
answer sally doesn't have two mommies
further the five-year-old boy who thinks
that he's a girl
is not a girl what should the teacher
say to the five-year-old boy who says
that he's a girl
the teacher should say you're not a girl
you're a boy
the teacher should affirm his actual sex
meaning
dispel the delusions that he has the
teacher should stand up for traditional
standards and mores and biology and
reality
we have got to remain in contact with
reality when you want to remain in
contact with all the people associated
with your business i would strongly
recommend you check out constant contact
i have been using constant contact for
something like 15 years now i have
relied on constant contact when i worked
my earliest campaign jobs when i've
worked with other companies it's a great
way to help get your business in order
and reach new people it's a digital
marketing platform that helps small
businesses and non-profits of all sizes
grow build and succeed they've got a 97
deliverability rate so you know when you
send something out there you are
reaching your people their list growth
tools help you to find a bigger audience
fast we're talking lead generation
landing pages text to join social media
ads they are a proven way to grow your
list and drive engagement with your
brand with thousands of integrations you
can sync constant contacts tools with
the tools that you're already using i
know that's always one big hassle at
companies when you start using some new
software you think is it going to
integrate do i have to switch everything
over constant contact makes it super
easy powerful automation tools help you
send the right message to the right
person at the right time every time to
start your free digital marketing trial
today head on over to
constantcontact.com
jen saki said yesterday two days ago
that this issue of transgendering the
kids makes her completely crazy and
those are the truest words that janzaki
has ever said it does make her crazy it
makes everyone who is in the thrall of
this weird transgender ideology
completely insane i'm at boston right
now i gave a speech last night at boston
university on this topic the topic was
teach the abcs not the lgbts
and the topic made people crazy there
were there were more shenanigans at this
speech i gave last night than i've seen
at a campus speech in years
first of all the event was sold out
and then the captain of the bu police
department wouldn't let half the
audience into the room
the captain of the bu police department
i don't know what his ax was to grind he
wouldn't let our photographer into the
rooms there actually aren't any even
professional photos from the event so
you had half of the room was stuck
outside and they had to stream the the
speech on their
phone and then of the people who were
let in there was a a planned walkout by
the left-wing lunatic kids i had an
inkling of who those kids were going to
be because they were all the only people
in the room with the masks this does
underscore my point my favorite part
about the airplane mask mandate being
lifted which is just that you can now
tell with 100 certainty exactly who the
libs are so you just know you're like
okay i guess i'm sitting next to one lib
and one normal person and that's okay
that's why just i'm just going to plan
out my conversation now i'm gonna plan
out my flight so i'm looking and i see
rows of these these students wearing the
masks and i think okay they're going to
stage some some protest
and right when i got to the topic of the
gender unicorn the gender unicorn is
this weird assignment about a purple
sexually confused unicorn that is being
handed out to third graders and second
graders in kindergarteners and even is
being used in certain pre-k classrooms
the gender unicorn and the gender-bred
man that's another
weird creepy
sexually confused cookie assignment
these are being used with really young
kids when i mentioned that the the kids
stormed up and flipped me off and yelled
and screamed and said all crazy things
and waved the transgender flag and then
walked out of the room this issue
makes
people
crazy and the the point i i drove home
last night at bu you can watch my speech
online uh it's it's been streamed to
youtube it's over at the yaf youtube
channel the point i made here is that
it's not enough just to stop the weird
sex lessons in the classroom you've got
to go further teachers need to teach
something it's not enough just to say
hey don't talk about transgenderism to
six-year-olds
well what are we gonna talk about
it's if if you're reading a story in a
kindergarten classroom and the story is
about a family of bears
mama bear daddy bear and and baby bear
i don't think anyone would object to
that right even though the lesson does
have implicit lessons about sex about
family about human nature where did baby
bear come from baby bear came from mama
bear and daddy bear and mama bear and
daddy bear live together in a marriage
because that's
a sort of ordinary normal thing to do
well what if the the story instead being
read to this kindergarten classroom were
about daddy bear and daddy bear's
boyfriend and daddy bear's boyfriend's
polyamorous trans billy goat and and
this were being read to five-year-olds
would we object to that i think we
probably would
we would you say don't no thank you
don't read that to my kid
both stories make implicit claims and
have implicit lessons about sex and
family and human nature but we like the
normal one and we don't like the one
with the trans billy goat
it's not just as some republicans are
saying it's not just that this education
law in florida
bans all sexual discourse entirely
sometimes you'll hear republicans say
you could you could call it the don't
say straight bill because it doesn't
discriminate between gay or straight or
trans or this it it just says all sexual
conduct is out but i just don't think
that's really what we're talking about
here i don't think that really gets to
the heart of the issue you can't teach
anything even even all the way down to
an elementary school classroom you can't
teach anything about
history literature biology certainly
civics you can't teach these things if
you don't
touch on topics involving
men and women and human nature that
those those things are just too
central sex and desire and family and
community those things are too central
to the human condition to avoid and so i
think we've got to stand up and say no
we have norms not saying we got to be
mean to gay guys not saying we need to
be cruel to people who are confused
about their sex but
we're allowed to have norms there's
nothing bigoted about that the reason
that republicans don't want to say any
of these things is because we're afraid
of being called a homophobe or a
transphobe or a phobe or whatever
nonsense slur the libs want to throw at
us but who cares they're going to throw
slurs at you anyway and what we're
standing up for is perfectly ordinary
and normal and everybody would have
agreed with it five years ago but now
you go to a college campus and people
lose their minds talking about a really
basic fact of human nature the craziest
protests i've ever had the only time i
was physically assaulted on a campus was
talking about this issue
this issue where the overton window as
it's sometimes called or the standards
have just completely changed to the
point that now you're not allowed to say
men and women are different
if you for instance
if you go on to twitter
and you don't make the general claim
that men and women are different but you
go in
you're you're retweeting bruce jenner
bruce jenner says i'm a woman and i want
to use the women's bathroom
let's say he's actually one of the least
offenders on this transgender ideology
but
let's go with it he's one of the most
prominent ones and he says i want to use
the women's bathroom and you retweet
that and you say you are not a woman
bruce jenner that's a violation of
twitter's
terms of conduct you you could lose your
twitter account for that
because the overton window has shifted
but if you retweeted some i don't know
straight white male and said you are a
terrible person and you are an oppressor
and you're the cause of all the evil in
the world you won't lose your twitter
account
the latter is objectively more offensive
than the former the latter is not true
while the former is true and yet you'll
be you'll be banned for saying the true
thing and you'll be fine for saying
the false thing which is why it's so
important that we get a hold on twitter
and facebook and google and the big tech
platforms that control our speech and
therefore control our democracy which is
why it's important that elon succeeds in
taking over twitter and there's some
news on this front
every day there's more news on elon's
hostile takeover of twitter and i'm here
for it i love it it's great
elon musk
bought over nine percent of twitter they
tried to put him on the board he
rejected the board seat because it would
have greatly limited his power he tried
to buy up the rest of the company the
twitter board issued a poison pill to
dilute everyone's shares of twitter and
offer every other shareholder the
ability to buy shares at a steep
discount except for elon musk to
basically make it prohibitive for elon
musk to take over twitter so that was it
right well not quite elon musk has then
cryptically been tweeting about the word
tender and the reason he's doing that is
because it seems like he wants to make a
tender offer where he goes directly to
the shareholders of twitter and just
buys their shares from them and then
eventually he'll have enough to control
twitter can elon actually do that well
we're getting reports out right now that
elon musk has secured 25 and a half
billion dollars
in financing to buy twitter from a group
of banks led by morgan stanley which
includes a 12.5 billion dollar uh
in-margin loan against
uh a 12.5 billion dollar margin loan
against his tesla shares so he's
leveraging his other company to buy
twitter and then musk has said that the
rest of the money 21 billion dollars
will come out of his own pocket
this is being reported after elon musk
has
filed with the sec the securities
exchange commission
all of which is to say i don't know how
this is going to end i don't know what
the board is going to do i don't know
what the next what the next
episode of this saga is going to be but
what that tells me is elon musk is
serious about it
and he's serious about buying twitter
because twitter is a serious problem we
joke about it we call it a hell site we
say we always too much time on it and
probably we do but twitter and to a
greater degree facebook and google
control our
speech control our discourse control our
whole political order and elon musk gets
it and he knows this is no laughing
matter he'll troll on twitter he'll joke
when he buys nine percent of the company
that when he buys the rest of it he's
going to take the w out t he he said
titter
but he's dead serious here
you don't spend 40 billion dollars on a
joke i don't think maybe jeremy would
maybe the god king of the daily wire
would spend 40 billion dollars on a joke
but there has to be a serious point here
and elon musk
is really proving it
i've been i've been sort of down in the
dumps
at how excited i am about the mask
mandate being taken away because i think
is this our new standard this is it hey
i get to breathe fresh air
score one for the conservatives that's
it that's our new standard or i'm a
little down in the doldrums about how
happy i am over the florida education
bill yeah we're gonna wait until kids
are nine to indoctrinate them into
transgenderism score one for the
conservatives that's it that's our new
standard that's all we can hope for it's
easy to be discouraged because the libs
have so much control over the culture
and the political order but you have to
remind yourself
take the win when you can get it take
the win when you can get it get those
marginal wins creep a little bit further
and further and further down the line of
where you want your political goal to be
which is a flourishing good free society
that's what the libs did for a century
and it gave them the country slowly
slowly slowly a long march through the
institutions we can take that ground
back it's popular it we've got the
common sense the elite institutions have
completely lost their credibility we can
do it but it's going to require patience
and determination
and and when we need a little relaxation
what are we going to do
why we're going to go
check out all form we're going to sit on
our great sofas right now go to all form
dot com slash knowles i've told you
about how great the helix mattress is
i've told you about that for years well
helix has a new company it's called all
form helix is leaving the bedroom
they're going into the living room in
the family room they have got phenomenal
sofas not only are they extremely high
quality aesthetically in terms of the
materials but also they're just very
very cool the way it works with all form
sofas is you can pick
what an armchair a love seat up to an
eight seat sectional you can pick your
fabric you can pick the sofa color you
can pick the leg color the sofa size the
sofa shape and then
you can grow the sofa as your home grow
so if you're in a studio apartment right
now you can start with a really small
one and then you can add on as you grow
it's phenomenal they've got a 100-day
decide if you want to keep it guaranteed
so if you don't like it they'll come
it's no big deal you can send it back
not a problem
they will pick it up for free they'll
give you a full refund they've also got
a forever warranty forever warranty so
right now to find your perfect sofa go
to allform.com
knowles all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners allforum.com
knowles
i am very pro-musk
i am pro-elon musk i don't know that i
agree with him on everything it's kind
of sad that the way that we take back
speech and political control in our
country these days is just to pit
billionaire oligarchs off of one another
but musk as far as billionaire
masters of the universe go musk seems
like one of the good guys and
the reason that i have a hunch that he's
one of the good guys is completely
unrelated to twitter or free speech or
big tech or the constitution it's
actually
it has to do with his answer to
a particular hobby horse of extremely
rich and powerful people for decades
actually for centuries now
very rich and very elite people
have worried about
overpopulation you saw this in the 1970s
especially there was a book called the
population bomb where all the genius
elite scientists who follow the science
and they're so smart and we should
follow them they said that it was
inevitable that within a decade you were
going to see mass famines around the
world you should encourage abortion you
should encourage contraception you
should coerce abortion and contraception
if need be and even then we're still
going to have mass famines and that's
just what's because we have too many
people in the world and then what
happened it's 50 years later the world
population has doubled since that time
and people are fatter than ever
malnutrition is at an all-time low and
elon musk has broken ranks with his
fellow billionaires and he's come out
and said the problem in the world today
is not overpopulation actually it's
under population
most people in the world are operating
under the false impression that uh that
there are too many people
this is not true earth could maintain a
population many times the current level
and the birth rate
has been
dropping like crazy um
so
and unfortunately like we have these
like
uh
ridiculous uh
population estimates from the un that
need to be updated because there just
don't make any sense
really you can just look at say
what was the
birth rate last year how many kids were
born multiply that by the
life expectancy and say okay that's how
many people will be alive
you know
in the future
and then say is the trend for birth rate
positive or negative it's negative
so that's the best case unless something
changes with the birth rate
very simple very correct and most
important of all very pro-human
elon musk might be the one billionaire
who
is pro-human
all the rest of these guys bill gates in
particular has this bizarre obsession
with overpopulation and trying to to
discourage birth rates and to try to
promote contraception and abortion and
things like that
this isn't some tinfoil hat stuff he's
he's promoted this on television for
decades at this point
and and all the rest of the libs are too
whether it's because of climate change
whether it's because
of i don't know all sorts of neuroses
that the libs have they want there to be
fewer people and it's it's always
interesting that the people prattling on
about overpopulation never volunteer to
help solve the problem
you notice that all the people who are
worried about overpopulation want
someone else's kids not to be born want
someone else's kids to be killed through
abortion it's never them it's never they
themselves who say you know okay i'll
check out there's too many people on
earth i'm out it's ronald reagan made a
similar point on abortion he said i
notice all the people who support
abortion have already been born
that's convenient isn't it
so it seems like it's out of left field
but elon musk's answer on that question
tells me
at a really basic fundamental level this
guy gets it
this guy one understands reality and
realizes that the earth could sustain
many times the number of people that are
currently on it but two he likes people
he's not a misanthrope he's not saying i
we need fewer people so that i can have
more stuff and money and resources
like all of the other rich guys you say
no we can have more people have more
people we don't have enough come on have
kids make a family
have some kids
let's go more people the more the
merrier
it's a very human perspective
speaking of humanity a really horrible
story coming out of los angeles homeless
deaths in los angeles have increased
over the past five years
this is people who die because of
exposure just die on the street and
they've increased not by a little bit
but by 200 percent in just five years
nearly 2 000 homeless people died in la
county last year according to a report
by the new york times 100 hundreds of
those who did so did so in plain sight
of passers-by people just walking on by
them
287 of these people died on the sidewalk
another 72 were found on the pavement
24 of them died in alleys
this is based on a report from the la
county coroner
is that humane
the libs tell us
that if if we do not let bums and
derelicts and mentally ill people and
addicts live and squalor on the street
that we're cruel we're anti-homeless
we're inhumane you think this is humane
i don't think this is humane at all
i think it's a horrible disordered thing
that we allow people to live on the
street
i remember back during occupy wall
street so this was probably 10 years ago
now rudy giuliani speaking of this as a
new yorker as someone who's the best
mayor of new york probably in that
city's history came out and he said this
is a simple question
don't let people live on the street
living on the street is a disordered act
that harms the individual and harm
society
why why are the libs in l.a doing this
they're doing this because
it's nice
they think it's the nice thing to do i
guess it is the nice thing to do it you
don't bother the homeless people you let
the drug addicts do what they want to do
at least what their appetites want to do
and you just hands off not my problem
i'm going to look away but it's not
loving
it's not loving at all you're letting
these people
live in squalor experience great pain be
completely discarded by society and then
die
and you're seeing their their
death numbers go through the roof
it would be much more loving to force
these people into homeless shelters
force these people into rehabilitation
centers force the criminals among these
people into prisons that would be much
more loving it's tough love sure but
it's a much more loving thing and that
that is the conservative answer
and what the libs want to convince us
that when we get back to reality and get
back to basics and enforce the
fundamental
lowest bar basic
functions of a society that we're cruel
and inhumane not at all it is completely
completely
the opposite
speaking of reality have you checked out
mount walsh's book yet johnny the walrus
matt walsh as you know is one of the
most cherished leading lgbtq plus
best-selling authors in the country he
is a scholar in the department of
women's studies a really really noted
uh
noted sexual theorist so matt has his
great book
that would be johnny the walrus it sold
out within 48 hours when it was released
don't worry more copies are on the way
so reserve your copy of johnny the
walrus over on amazon we'll be right
back with a lot more
welcome back to the show
my favorite time of the week we are now
in the mailbag first question up from
brandon dear michael did you ask your
wife's father for his blessing in
marriage before you propose to her the
reason i ask is because i plan on
proposing in the near future however i'm
not sure if i respect her liberal dad
for constantly calling me every name in
the book for being a conservative he's
also pretty frustrated that i converted
his daughter to a conservative christian
and we have plans on moving from
california to texas i know that he wants
me to ask him but to point out the
hypocrisy
he never asked his wife's father for his
blessing i'm just curious what your
thoughts are yes i did ask my
father-in-law's blessing i like my
father-in-law a lot sounds like you
don't really like your father-in-law
very much but you should ask his
blessing anyway
not because your father-in-law is some
great guy but because it's the right
thing to do
the the
the
act of asking a blessing
is
uh not so much about the people involved
the prospective groom and the
father-in-law as it is about the act
itself it's a good respectful act
it's the sort of thing that good
civilized young men will do
and so whether you're doing it for him
or not whether he plays any factor into
your thoughts on do you should do it for
yourself and you should do it because
it's the right thing to do young man
from
uh george michael i wanted to get your
opinion on having arguments with
leftists in comment sections online i
often find myself getting into these
arguments on youtube and the lion's den
tiktok in which i can probably count on
one hand the number of times the
discussion has ended peacefully or in
good faith most of the time the other
side will start resorting to insults
mid-conversation or start talking to me
in a condescending manner my question is
is it worth participating in these
arguments at all or should we just let
them be
it is not worth participating and you
should just let them be
yes that's it the definition of madness
is doing the same thing over and over
again and expecting different results
right i'm not saying you should
necessarily get off of social media i'm
not even saying you should necessarily
stop voicing your opinions on social
media but there is really no reason for
you to get into fights in the comment
section
and these long threads you're probably
not going to convince the person you're
talking to now there might be a side
benefit of this which is you might
convince people who happen to be reading
the thread
this is the purpose of really big public
debates when you have a dinner party and
you go out and have drinks and cigars
and you start talking to someone you
could have a maybe a private debate and
potentially persuade the other person or
that person could persuade you when
you're standing on a stage having a
formal debate the point is not to
persuade the other person the point is
to score as many points as you can and
persuade people in the audience that's
pretty much the same thing that you're
seeing in social media so
you might get something out or someone
else might benefit
from that or you might just make your
point in the comment section
and then let it go
and move on with your life and you'll
have more time to make more comments and
do things that are more productive and
more
edifying chris says michael i was
sexually assaulted in january by a woman
i work with as much as the libs would
have you believe females assaulting
males is not happening and if it is
happening it's really not that big of a
deal i didn't fear for my physical
safety but i was deathly afraid of how
it would affect my marriage i struggled
with myself over whether i should tell
my wife what happened and pray we would
get through it or hide it from her out
of shame i decided the best outcome was
to be completely truthful with her about
it and thank god my wife didn't blame me
at all while my wife wanted to do some
terrible things to the woman that
assaulted me we decided i wouldn't
report the assault out of fear of
retaliation from the woman and possibly
my job given the hashtag metoo sku in
favor of women ironically my wife and i
have never been closer and our emotional
connection has reached a deeper level i
think i know your answer but what is
your opinion on tragic and emotionally
distressing things bringing a marriage
closer together well that certainly
happens
shared experience is a really important
part of marriage i asked my grandfather
this my grandfather and grandmother have
best marriage i've ever seen they've
been married for about a bazillion years
and i asked him years and years ago even
before i was about to propose i said
maybe this was on his 60th wedding
anniversary i said what's the key to a
good marriage
and my grandfather said patience
shared experience
and frequent absence because he was a
captain in the navy and so he would he
would deploy for long periods of time
and that was pretty funny joke there's
probably some truth to that actually too
but shared experience is a really
important one because you're going to
grow together or grow apart and it
doesn't mean
just going on fun rides at disney world
it doesn't mean just that that great
vacation to hawaii and all the happy
memories but the sad memories too will
bring you closer together as well as
they are shared experiences
as for
telling your wife you know i don't know
the details of this assault sometimes
it's hard to even picture it because you
think well if some woman is going to
come up and assault you why don't you
just push her out of the way you're
bigger
presumably but i don't know i mean
obviously it does happen so i'm not i'm
not disputing that
but in terms of your struggle with this
do i tell my wife you know it's kind of
maybe you feel embarrassed about it
maybe you feel some shame about it well
you certainly shouldn't feel any shame
in that
unless you were participating unless
this is not just a clear cut assault you
didn't do anything wrong in order to
commit a sin that it requires an act of
the will certainly to commit morals and
requires an act of the will and you were
an unwilling participant here
and this issue in particular is coming
up because of this case of uh between
johnny depp and amber heard a defamation
case that johnny depp is bringing
because of this very acrimonious breakup
between the two i have not been watching
the case
because i'm a grown man and i'm not
we got other things to do but but it is
fascinating the reports that i've been
reading about it because this woman
amber heard seems to be a complete
looney tune and just extraordinarily
manipulative and wicked and just a
terrible person and poor johnny depp
does seem generally like the victim here
so so what's the answer to that i've had
people write into me say
similar points
michael can you please talk about woman
on male domestic violence and so what
what do you do with that well i i still
come down to the point that
the men need to handle it
the men need to get a hold on things
okay the men need to lead here and so
it's bad you might find yourself with a
complete lunatic like amber heard
but
but still it's kind of on you to take
some control of the situation and if
something goes wrong and if you suffer
in some way you shouldn't feel any shame
about that unless unless you're willing
participant from
andrew hello nostradamus this may be a
triggering question to some
though i
expect not too many of the daily wire
subscribers do you think there is any
correlation with the current movement of
gender ideology and self-identity with a
diagnosed or undiagnosed mental disorder
throughout history many topics that
these agendas are pushing could land
someone in a mental institution is it
possible we're seeing history repeat
itself or simply a minority of confused
individuals now have the ability to
indoctrinate impressionable minds at the
click of a button well of course i mean
if you're a man who thinks that he's a
woman then you have a mental disorder
you have a very acute very clear mental
disorder there's no no question about
that it's it's in the diagnostic and
statistical manual it's in the dsm the
the
textbook of psychiatry so that's
certainly the case uh there is a social
phenomenon too though
because while a very small number of
people suffer from this acute
psychological condition where you have
confusion about your sex
the the numbers are now exploding
because it's also a social phenomenon
and because these delusions are being
affirmed by all of the institutions of
power whether we're talking about the
white house whether we're talking about
corporations whether we're talking about
big tech whether we're talking about a
kindergarten teacher everyone is
affirming this madness that boy can
become a girl and so
there are some people who
might not have severe psychiatric
conditions who are just going along with
this because it's in the zeitgeist it's
blowing along and that's a big problem
and and we need a little bit of tough
love here i think we need to stop being
so nice and be a little bit tougher and
more loving and tell people who are
confused no you're not
a woman and even even conservatives need
to get tougher on this conservatives try
to split the baby and so they'll say
well if a grown man wants to pretend
that he a grown man who is wearing a
dress who calls himself sally if he
wants to pretend that he's a woman
that's his right that's totally fine but
just don't do it to little kids no it's
not his right he has no right you have
no right to delusion
and we have no obligation as a society
to indulge delusion no matter what the
ruling class tells us
no you got you we actually have an
obligation to tell him the truth and say
no buster you're not take the dress off
stop calling yourself sally sally's a
girl's name you're sam you're a boy
sam's kind of an androgynous name anyway
so there you go and you can't use the
girls room and you can't swim on the pen
girl swim team and you gotta you gotta
come back to reality
from julia
dear smokey mike is there any way you
can send out the chords to together
again from your original album i promise
i won't steal anything i'm just not good
enough to figure out what chords to play
and i can't get the song out of my head
love smokey mike's number one fan girl
p.s don't tell jeremy but i'll be on
your side 100 when the band breaks up
thank you julia you're obviously a woman
of discerning taste
um
i can't send you the chords two together
again because i don't remember them i
realized this the other day i pulled out
my guitar i was playing guitar and my
son was playing around if you're gonna
play a little guitar for him and i
remembered at the guitar solos i was
kind of playing this up but i realized i
couldn't
i couldn't remember exactly how to play
the song i'm sure i could remember it
and figure it out pretty quickly but
it's that's what happens with music
magic you know these things just pop out
of
the god king's head
he did write that song in the shower he
literally wrote that song standing in
the shower pops out of the god king's
head
and we sit there you know like
1970s national treasure rock star as we
play it
then it's gone man it's in the ether
if you if you want it again you gotta
just keep clicking play on spotify
on apple music on youtube
from nick uh-oh
nick we've missed nick hey michael me
again i'm sorry for being m.i.a the past
few months i've been on a spiritual
journey
so apparently there's this thing called
ayahuasca long story short i fell off my
king energy and was seduced by another
goddess who loves crystals i was
listening to joe rogan and got really
into the beatles none of which i'm proud
of after i lost track of sydney in tulum
and made it back to the states i
couldn't shake the ayahuasca trip i felt
like i saw and spoke to other beings it
was nuts do you think ayahuasca and dmt
make you hallucinate or finally see
what's already there as a spiritual dude
who doesn't do drugs i figured you could
tell me what's up this is actually a
good question nick and i get this from a
lot of people
they'll say hey man you know i don't i'm
not religious or nothing i'm not one of
you crazy christians or nothing you know
but i do a bunch of drugs and i and i
see lots of spirits man you know and i
so i believe in that you know
i think oh so you believe in demons okay
you don't believe in angels and god but
you do believe in demons okay i don't do
drugs i've never been into drugs the the
hardest drug i've ever had was a puffer
two on the old haitian oregano but it
does not interest me because i i don't
want brain damage and i think i rely on
my brain i think it's working okay right
now and if i want to explore
metaphysical questions like you're
talking about i would like to do it in a
way that is rigorous that is not that
does not involve me losing control of my
rational faculties and my will like you
do when you do drugs but that actually
focuses my intellectual faculties and my
and my will
on things like philosophy and theology
that applies intellectual rigor to all
of these questions so what are people
seeing when they take ayahuasca or dmt
or whatever other mushrooms or acid what
are they seeing
well
they could be hallucinating probably
that's a big part of it but also
we there is more between heaven and
earth than is dreamt of in our
philosophies horatio also there is a
spiritual reality to the world there are
angels and there are demons and there is
spiritual battle and there's good and
bad and right and wrong and we're in
that and we hit we are bodies but we're
also souls and so that that stuff is
real
and when you
lose control of your intellect and your
will you open yourself up to a lot of
potentially pretty nasty things and that
that's that's real i mean we talk about
spirits you know forget about ayahuasca
for a second let's say you just go out
and you drink too much
you're opening yourself up by drinking a
lot of spirits you are opening yourself
up in a way to spirits because you're
you're no longer as in control of your
will so long and short nick is
don't do drugs buddy
go to church open your bible and go to
church from
jen
jen nostradamus you are the very person
i believe can help me answer this
question about evangelization it is my
understanding that catholics slash
christians should spread the word of god
but how can one do that without being an
overbearing jesus freak to those around
them or how can i tell my friends of
that
description how to chill it's a good
question friend of mine
when he was
when he was converted when he
described this experience of of just
being opened to the holy spirit
he said his first thought was dear god
please don't make me a jesus freak
and he meant that's actually a good
place please
and i i had a pretty radical reversion
as well in my after college in my early
20s it was a process that was gradual
and then sudden so i really can
empathize with what you're talking about
here and everyone when people convert or
revert i have noticed they go through a
very intense period where they're pretty
weird because it's a it's a pretty wild
experience uh so i
i suppose my prudential judgment here
though is
if you want to
persuade people if you want to convert
people you can't seem like you're just
completely off your rocker
you can be joyful you can be excited you
can be eager to spread the joy that
lives within you but you've got to be
grounded in reality as well don't forget
the gospels are not poetry they're not
philosophy the gospels are
news reports the gospels are journalism
accounts and and the rest of the new
testament is letters
it's grounded in real hard
facts that's where the hope lies
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
show i'll see you monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin